hey everybody dog walker Here I am going
to be talking about dr. strange
apologies that Rob isn't here he is
actually gonna review it on awesome
comics and I was gonna be on there but
I'm going out this weekend to help Brad
shoot his movie so this is just my
facile v-log my two cents on what I
thought about it I was getting really
good reviews I think last time I saw is
that like 91% or something like that so
a lot of people are liking it and yeah I
liked it too it's just another decent
good Marvel movie um you know it's not
perfect uh but I don't know if people
are gonna be shouting like this is
perfect what what is perfect about is
its visual style which you've seen in
the trailers and such and it's not one
of those movies where it's like oh well
just that stuff was in the trailer now
there's a lot of really really cool
stuff and it's a fun and it's got some
great comedy to it and the characters
are likable the action is so creative
it's kind of like they saw inception and
said oh yeah we're gonna do that times
10 because it's kind of the same ideas
it reminded me a lot of that of like the
city folding and moving and running
across you know upside-down rooms and
buildings and such and so it has that
feel but again I think because it's also
a comic book movie you could sort of go
even more because it's Marvel you know
they have a ton of money they're gonna
throw a ton at it so it looks really
great on top of that just the surreal
imagery is phenomenal uh this I don't a
lot of people are probably to be like oh
well I got a toke up and go in and watch
it I wouldn't advise that
ah because is some scenes are fine with
that but there's some other scenes like
the first time he gets zapped into
whatever you want call the other realm
ah it's it's pretty fast and intense and
they throw a lot of stuff at you and
it's great you don't need drugs for it
it don't make you feel high um so uh all
of that is really really cool I'm really
good the basic story is that it's um
Cumberbatch plays a guy named dr.
strange who is a doctor and he's kind of
Tony Stark ish honestly maybe a little
too similar but he brings his own flair
to it you know he makes his own thing
and he is this phenomenal doctor and he
gets in a car accident where his hands
get really scratched up and that's it
what I mean by that is if you see this
car crash this is like it over-the-top
cartoony car crash like car hits a me
spins around goes off a cliff while
still spinning hits the ground just
tumbles around all this stuff and
everything and then lands in this river
and it's like upside down like this and
he wakes up and he has all these things
in his hands and like some cuts and
bruises cut two months later all my
hands oh no my hands it is like dude how
do you still have a spleen it's
ridiculous but uh you'll find the whole
movie kind of works this way if you're
looking for plot holes you'll find
plenty uh but I don't think people are
when they see a Marvel film or even a
comic book film they're kind of looking
for the motivations to carry them
through and the likeability of the
characters and that is what carries it
through even when they're unlikable like
this guy you know has this doctor a
works with and you know kind of on-again
off-again relationship and she's been
taking care of him and he just freakin
you know just blows up on her says some
really tough means and things and even
though everyone the audience was just
like oh and yet you still like this dude
somehow uh and I think because they do
show that he tries to come back from a
tries to be better and he is against or
the Tony Stark ish archetype where it's
like he can be so unlikable but there's
just there is this charm there is this
intrigue there is this passion that sort
of makes you want to follow him that
somehow it doesn't make you hate him and
I don't know what the magic formula is
or the magic balance but but they got it
they got it with him the guy with Tony
Stark
sometimes they almost lose it with Tony
star there are times where I'm just like
come on here's my address
come on um but it could just be the
actors the actors are so good the
editing is so tight and writing so tight
um so he wants his gift bag he wants his
hands back because they shake now again
unbelievable he has hands at all or any
body parts but so he goes and he finds
this
ancient temple where he finds the
ancient one and she shows them how to
you know manipulate reality and how
everything is of the spirit a lot of
Eastern philosophies and such and he
learns and there's this evil bad guy who
wants to take one of the many magic
books in this library and wants to use
it for evil to let this evil universe
bad God come in again comic books um and
destroy everything because he lost
everything a long time ago and he's like
I want to destroy time I wanted to it's
just typical Marvel villain who's kind
of boring and you see him a million
times but to its credit out of all the
boring Marvel villains this one probably
is the most interesting in his boredom
what I mean by that is his delivery is
very deadpan but it's kind of enjoyable
deadpan he has this very controlled look
just very you know but when he needs to
say something funny as this great
contemplation and there's this great
scene where strange he's in this uh he's
in this room of all sorts of weird
artifacts and weapons I can do strange
things they doesn't understand and he
finds one that he holds it to the guy in
the Ville and goes oh like that and you
know come branches like aha the film
looks at me goes you don't know how to
use that do you and he just tosses it at
him but the way he delivers that you
don't know how to use that to you it's
this wonderful sort of inner calm it's
like maybe that's the fun of him is that
there is kind of this inner calm too and
it makes him a little bit more interest
in the other Marvel villains but until
then Loki's still the past a little
weird but yeah I mean that's not what
you're focusing on though I mean Marvel
is much more about the heroes that is
the villains around the movies I should
say comics the villains are pretty good
um so yeah and it's all about them
trying to stop this guy from opening the
portal which to be fair isn't just a
laser in the sky at least this time I'm
so sick of those beams going in the sky
and opening up the clouds this one's
pretty trippy and that's the best way I
can describe and it's a comic book movie
and it combines them it really has fun
with them uh it never goes
to abstract it's always aware it's a
Marvel comic book movie but the nice
thing about it too is that you you swear
they're listening to us which i think is
so great because a lot of people been
saying you know these Marvel movies are
good but getting well tired of all the
connections all the cameos and all the
hey here's Iron Man I need you to have
already flies by whatever and they take
that out in this one like I think they
mentioned the Avengers once you see like
the building once but there's not a
cameos that I remember uh and they do
build up stuff in the future movies
which again are a little weak like with
this way if you are looking for stuff to
not like in this movie first of all why
are you seeing the movie if that's the
case second um you're gonna find them
there's a lot of things that don't make
sense in this movie and the main
villains motivation is explaining the
other villain that they're hinting at at
the end does not feel very well
explained and I can't act like I don't
get why that is because there's a lot of
explaining in this movie it's kind of
amazing you stay with it as long as you
do because we really there's a lot of
great visuals and stuff but it's kind of
like wow I'm just realizing all this
stuff in terms of talking that they
throw at you it's a lot of information
and you do follow it just enough but
it's also just enough to sort of say
wait this guy's gonna be bad now because
of that and this person doesn't get
better security around this place that's
probably my biggest problem the security
for these books and these techniques is
the freakin worst like I actually laugh
out loud every single time someone
breaks into this library it actually
opens up with the world's worst security
this guy's in this library and here's
these books and these very pointless
chain locks you know obviously not gonna
do a thing and they just four guys come
in like pull them up cut off his head
and then just steal a book actually not
even a book a page and you know the
ancient ones like Dowell and she goes
after and tries to stop them but even
folding buildings and stuff can't quite
do it so now they have to up security
they get another guy to go in there
watch of the books and guess what he
sucks added like dr. strange figures out
how to teleport and stuff like that he
just teleports these little hands that
go in and grab the books almost like a
cartoon and it's like it's one guy what
he's listening to music while this is
going on and then at the very end like
you know the ancient building of
whatever this is about to be attacked
it's like a super important building
that can't be attacked so you see them
all line up the guy that protects the
library he's the leader of this and he
goes he's like don't let anybody get
inside and then you see dr. strange show
up and just the buildings toppling over
it I just how can you not laugh at that
just how awfully protected the ancient
secrets and the world blowy up things
are I mean these are like it's like
information on how to just unleash bad
guy you know coming in to destroy
everything and it's one guy one guy who
doesn't even do his job very well uh on
top of that if you want get into
technicals there's all sorts of things
of like wait if they could bend this why
can they bend that if they could use
this as a weapon why can they use it
here it's sort of all that Marvel x-men
technical stuff that if you really think
about it doesn't add up at all but I
think that is kind of the leeway that
you give with it being a comic book
movie because that's like I says not
what you're looking for you're looking
for the characters being interesting in
the story being engaging and an excuse
they have some really cool action and
visuals and when it does slip out of
those continuities you know that the
logical and accuracies you it's not too
distracting you know it's one of the
things where you're so distracted by how
well everyone else is doing and the
action is and the visuals and the ideas
and the characters that you you're not
distracted by it unless you really want
to go looking for it which if you do
there's plenty there are tons tons of
things that don't make sense
um but you don't want to see that you
want to see Benedict Cumberbatch put on
the cool cape put on the really bad
American accent he's he's very Hugh
Laurie in this with a lot of people fell
for Hugh Laurie so maybe he will hear -
I thought was pretty fake
um but he's fine you should just made
him British heaven it takes place in
Britain anyway he's just made him a Brit
um but uh yeah it's it's one of those
films where it's like it came out and
visually I was blown away because we saw
it in IMAX in 3d and we usually don't
like to see movies like this one's worth
it that this is definitely like one of
the top four or five
3d IMAX movies I've seen because they do
new stuff with the technology actually
before played they had a trailer for
rogue one in 3d and it was not good 3d
like it was just blurry and sloppy
couldn't focus on anything I'm just like
oh no like is this what dr. strange is
gonna be but it wasn't and to give you
an idea how good this 3d is it opens up
in this dark rooms as sort of this dark
temple and here's this pillar the pillar
is completely black like it's in the
dark and you're going pass it even
though it's completely in the dark it
feels like it's really close to you like
that's good 3d that's a very impressive
3d especially you usually need a lot of
light to make 3d work but they they got
that I don't know what they did but they
got into very very well um so I would
advise your go see a CNN iMac see a 3d
it is worth the extra money and putting
on the annoying glasses it is worth it
so this is one of the few I mean I'm
thinking like which ones was I like Hugo
I think I said that how to train a
dragon I think I said that um you know
an avatar so yeah that's uh you know
just about for I can think of I had like
you know just primo amazing 3d um trying
to think anything else anything else uh
it's just a fun comic book movie I mean
it is exactly what it is I don't think
story wise or character wise it's among
like one of the best of the Marvel
movies you know especially after Civil
War which was so well done um but but
it's extremely entertaining every single
time you think like um it's a lot of
talking and this it goes to the cool
action scenes every time you think the
action scenes might be going on too long
or you want change of environment or
something they do that so they sort of
give you
anything you want just at the right time
or maybe just as you're starting a
little bored of it bedrooms going to be
different so I really enjoyed it if you
want to nitpick it you definitely can I
have not read the comics I know nothing
about Doctor Strange so I have no idea
how close they got these characters or
not
so yeah it's uh it's kind of like out of
the best way play it's every Marvel
movie you've ever seen but I mean they
in a good way it you just kind of look
forward to these and the one plus it has
is the visual style which I mean this
must be just bad designers what shame I
mean like it looks gorgeous all the
things they throw at you and the speed
they throw at you and the technology
they use to bring to life Rob and I were
talking like we said this is what CG is
made for you know we're not anti CG but
we do think it's overused everywhere
this is a movie where it's like yes use
it it just engulfed it I mean this is
where it belongs and these kind of
visuals and ideas and it really takes
advantage of and it really takes
advantage of the 3d as well especially
the scenes where you can kind of they're
like ghost people and you can see
through them like in a movie that's
night that just kind of transparent some
other parts art or whatever but in 3d
especially as one scene where two ghost
people are talking to each other and you
can kind of see through him and he can
kind of see through her but it's not
like that
lame effect were because he's in front
of her you can't see her then it's like
no you can kind of see him to see her
and it's really well done in 3d it just
looks so so good so definitely advise
you seeing it that way um yeah fun movie
uh like I say it's not maybe it probably
isn't like one of my top three favorite
Marvel movies or anything like that but
it's just a good standard fun
entertaining visually exciting movie and
definitely worth your time so that's my
two cents don't forget to check out all
some comics you can see what Rob thought
of it and I shall talk to you guys later
take care